all right
and give us a moment uh everyone while
we get set up for the webinar
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
one moment please
all right and welcome everyone
to our expert webinar
you mastering the art of problem solving
career tips for digital transformation
job roles
our guest today is dr len bertain who is
the ceo
of the consortium of problem solvers
and i'm stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn
and i want to thank you all for being
here before we
start with len's presentation um a few
questions
or tips about how to use the webex
controls first off
uh place getting questions you have for
when
into the q a box we will keep track of
those
and then we'll address those in the q a
toward the end of the presentation
he tells me he has time to take quite a
few of those
so please put those in the q a box
anything you put in the chat box
if you want us to see it please address
it to all
panelists and
as i said we'll be keeping track of that
information
addressing it toward the end of the
presentation we'll also be doing
a couple of polls during the
event and i'm going to start with the
first one as a practice poll but it also
gives us a little bit of feeling for the
audience
so if you're watching on our streaming
channels you can put answers to these
questions in your
comments um
if you're in webex you see a widget now
with the poll
first how much experience do you have in
your career
and the second question is something
we've been asking during the pandemic
how are you doing today um i'd like to
check in with people because
the world is a very different place than
it was just a year and a half ago so
got about 15 seconds left on the pole
and
you see me shaking it's because we have
cats
and they do knock the monitor a little
bit
um
the poll results show that
the biggest chunk of our audience are
folks with more than 10 years of
experience
so we have a experienced audience but
what len will present
meat applies to everybody here today and
it's good to see
that um the vast majority of you are
doing well or
at least okay and we hope that after the
webinar
you'll have some great information that
you can use to
brighten your mood so with that
i am going to introduce uh
pardon me dr len bertain um
len and i have known each other for 40
years and uh he is the ceo of the
consortium
of problem solvers um he has solved
problems for over 200 ceos
focusing on problems that have a hundred
to one roi solutions
and he'll address how he does that
over the years he's generated over a
billion dollars
in first year profits over 200
clients that means they have improved
their businesses
to the extent that they have made a
billion dollars more than they would
have
without his help he has a couple of
books
out including 567 problem solving how to
solve wicked problems
correctly and uh welcome len
i am going to stop sharing my screen and
turn it over to you
up let me unmeet you there we are
there you go go ahead
it didn't share yet yeah it's coming
so lynn how are you doing today i'm good
and you should have control now
apologize for the delay it's a
thing about webex is it's
not really as easy to use as with all
that
where did your tab go where did that go
you have to reopen the tab
and then go to view present
view yeah there you go
all right pardon the uh
uh cockpit errors here uh
as stewart indicated he and i have known
each other for
over 40 years and he'd asked me to
participate in this program and
i wanted to talk about what i've done
over the last 35 years in
teaching people the art of program
problem solving
and the key to this is
what what i like to say is that we don't
want to automate
waste in other words you want to fix the
problems first
that have the hundred and to one roi
and then once you get those fixed then
you could start looking at digital
transformation and i would like to talk
a little bit about
how we do that um
the bottom line of everything i've done
over the last 35 years is i respect
all ideas and
i really empower workers
and all of my clients
to go for it and to get success that way
uh and i'd like to just tell a brief
story
one of my very first classes that i
taught was at 6 30 in the morning
and i had i was going to be teaching the
company about the
toyota production system and i had 100
and
160 slides we were going to cover those
over the
next 10 weeks three days a week an hour
for class
and i'm in the first class 6 30 in the
morning and this lady raises her hand
about 15 minutes into the class
and she says how long is this going to
be and i
repeated what i just said and it was
going to be 10 weeks
and hour for class and she goes oh
god is this going to be boring
and i go well hold it you know i'm
thinking to myself this is the great len
bertain giving a presentation up here
come on call it you know
and i so i rather than shut her off i
just said
well why is that and she said well i'm
illiterate
and i go oh man you know
you think of everything that could
possibly go wrong in a class oh boy did
that one just slap me in the face and it
was like
it told me that i could not spend 10
weeks with these people
blabbing up in the front for slide after
slide for this lady so i
immediately changed what i was doing and
you'd
use the slides as guides to
direct the process over the next 10
weeks and we solved a big problem for
the company
and it was a lot of fun
but
when i began the process of problem
solving the first thing i do is try to
get clear on what the company's
value proposition is what they do to
value
the added value that they deliver to the
market
and surprisingly very few people are
crystal clear about that
people come to work they leave at the
end of the day and they don't even think
about
what they're doing to make money for the
company
you know you just you know you put up
with the boss and you go home at the end
of the day and that's it
and but what you really have to do
is look at the value-added part of the
of the day and initially when i started
this in that class
first class i instead of saying
essential support functions i
refer to them as necessary waste
and needless to say over the next three
or four class
companies that i work with that didn't
go well so i changed it to
what you see today essential support and
those are the jobs that support the
adding of value
accounting functions the guy on the dock
shipping things out the door and then
the question is
is what are those things that don't add
value when aren't essential support
that's waste
and if you've got any understanding of
the toyota production system they go
into great detail about waste
but the very simple understanding of it
is anything that doesn't add value to
waste so if you move something from
point a to b
that didn't change the identity of a
manufacturing product
or if you're in a hospital and
you wheel the car a patient from
point a to b uh that's
that's not necessarily waste but the
question is
is when the patient sits in his bed
and waits after he pushes the emergency
button and
waits uh a minute and a half
that's waste and so all of the
businesses of the world that i work with
you know banking all of them they all
have to
you have to look at the business problem
solving from this perspective and that's
the way we start it
i begin by looking at
what it is the strategy of the business
and you can listen to all kinds of
examples of what it is
but very simply if you look at strategy
as the value proposition of the business
in other words
what are you telling the market
that you're going to do to make money
and to be
a presence in the market so example the
ceo of a small business might want to be
the leader in internal growth
versus using external growth which is
acquisitions and whatnot so if you're
going to be a leader in internal growth
how are you going to do that what are
the things you're going to do internally
to increase the chances of being the
leader in that particular aspect of
of your business and then
but the question is how do you check
strategy
and what i've done over the years and
noticed is that when you
when you're trying to identify
a waste there's a link back
to the strategy because why is that
well what is a waste what is a problem
that you're dealing with it's a waste
and a waste is
anything that gets in the way of adding
value so there's a link between solving
a problem
and strategy and i don't think
very many of my clients ever thought of
that before i walked in the door
and so that's what that's what we try to
do when we
solve problems we try to get the ceo
tied in to the problems that are being
solved
and to watch how their strategy changes
and i'll give you some examples
of how that happened in a couple of
appliances that i have
but the ceo needs to know what his
weaknesses are
of his strategy and that's what this is
all about
i'm going to talk a little bit later
about why you need
a problem-solving strategy
these are the five pillars of my
problem-solving
program for the last 30 years for the
first 30 years
the last five we'll talk about that in a
second
and that's more of a internet based
problem solving process
but the first one is no blame that's
change without reprisal
literally when i walked into the first
class
that hit me in the face and i'll talk
about that on the next slide
but you have to have
an agreement before you begin
that you can put ideas into play that
might impede on somebody's ego
and you don't care about that it's not
an
issue of ego or protection of
of territory for a manager
but it's rather getting to the root
cause of a problem
the other thing we do is look at
empowered teams and
you know it was sort of a fun thing over
the years when we've done this a couple
times somebody comes up to me and says
you mean to say we're not just talking
about this we're going to have to go out
and implement our idea and i go yep
that's what this is all about
because the issue is is you know ceos
tell me you look at i
you know there are some ideas that i
i've never been able to get around to
see if you can get those in place some
way and i'm pretty good at
getting people to buy into some of those
ideas and the ceo
after we've gotten them implemented he
just hits his head you know oh my god
you know why didn't i
you know it's so easy to get lost in the
shuffle of day-to-day production and
day-to-day activity just doing your job
not
thinking about it um
but the idea of having an empowered team
that actually gets something done
then we look at high roi that's a
hundred to one
for large companies let's say fortune
two thousand
smaller companies let's say under uh 200
million
i give them fifty to one instead of a
hundred to one
and the the reason is somebody said
about
large companies that much more fit
inefficient and i go yep they are
and that and people say well we don't
we're not that inefficient we can't find
those kind of things and i've been doing
this now for
uh 35 years and i have yet
to walk into a company that i couldn't
find
multiple problems that are equated to 50
to 1
and in a large corporations
i i could be there until
eternity and still keep busy
then we have a six-step process and our
process is basically step one is
identify a problem
step two is look for the root cause
and it's pretty obvious you know you can
go to the
steps one and two can usually go pretty
quick but sometimes
that not so because you end up
arguing internally about what really is
the problem
you know you you go down one path and
that's what you think the problem is but
the real root cause
as an example would be
you can't get uh orders
out the door quick enough and it turns
out that
the setup of jobs internally within the
company is like eight hours
per job when you can reduce it to less
than an hour
and speed that process up but the root
cause
is different than well originally i'll i
have examples of that that i can talk
about
but it's it's a big deal the third thing
is how big is the problem in the course
if you look at the waste associated with
the problem how big is it
gonna be over the waste over the year
and
that's what the hundred thousand dollars
or the
hundred to one hundred dollars that was
addressing how big that problem
is the fourth step is look at
the solution and it has to be 101
ratio to the let's say if you identify
10 million dollars worth of waste
then uh a hundred to one to that
is you can have a hundred thousand
dollars
of solution and you know just
it's funny i did a project project with
five years ago with the ceo and the
c-level executives at a company and i
said well you have to
find a hundred to one and you have to
have at least a billion dollars of waste
and you but you can't spend more than 10
million dollars and
these guys going oh my god you can't do
that but
it's all a matter of perspective and
then we look at
567 as is like five percent of the
effort to get
67 percent of the benefit the easiest
way to see that
is when you're writing software about
doing software development you go for
five percent of the features that are
going to give you the benefit and get
people
buying that software and then adding
features over time
google's really good at that in fact
that's they've mastered that art
of throwing a few features out there to
get you to
interested in what they were trying to
do and
you know the next thing you know it's uh
it's a full-fledged product
but usually five percent is is
enough to get uh people convinced and
you know that's what happened at apple
when they did the iphone they
had four different groups presenting uh
ideas to steve jobs and
they have limited number of functions
but enough to convince
jobs that he should go ahead with
funding the project
um talking about no blame
quickly the
initial time i encountered no blame was
in the very first class when i said okay
are there any problems that you can see
in the business that we'd like to talk
about
and all the hands go up in the class i
called on a guy in the front row and
before he answered he turned around and
looked at the back and there was a door
and he was worried that the manager that
would be
yes nasty manager might stick his head
in the door
where he puts an idea into play that
reflect negatively on the manager the
second guy does the same thing the third
one
but they put their ideas into play
and then i'm i'm going there's something
wrong here and he's
i said he's worried about getting blamed
and whatever so i went put up
put this signal or sign up on the board
and from that point on that's been 35
years i've been using this and i finally
registered
about 23 years ago
and it's the basis of change without
reprisal you have to have
an agreement on this before you proceed
this is a quote from east of eden by
john steinbeck and i read it a number of
years ago and i really
it caught my attention and it really is
something i believe
is that the free exploring mind of the
individual human
is the most valuable thing in the world
and this i would fight for
the freedom of the mind to take any
direction it wishes
undirected and this i might fight
against
any idea religion government and i put
in
or corporations which limits or destroys
the individual
this is what i am and this is what i'm
about
now it sounds tacky but on the other
hand it really is
an important thing to do if you're going
to go in and try to help people solve
problems
you're going to get if you're going to
use people in in
from all walks of parts of the business
you have to respect them and that's what
this is about
more about the 567
if you notice on this graph
that the normal 80 20 rule which is you
know 80 percent of the
benefit comes from 20 percent of the
effort
um or
80 percent of your problems come from 20
of your customers the same applies to
the 567 rule
5 of your uh
customers generate 67 of your complaints
but you'll notice that at the 567 it's
very steep
so there's a lot of latitude there that
as you move up or down that curve
you're going to get a lot of uh of
movement of the
of the various numbers and the way this
came about is
early on when i was doing the war on
waste i
i didn't have a lot of time and so i
would say
you know the people are saying i can't
collect 20 percent of the information
well just collect five percent of it and
we'd end up with 60 to 70 percent
and i go wow so maybe there's something
here and then
so i formalized it
a friend of mine uh actually helped me
do that
another corollary to that is the 120
20 rule of profits and
the reason this can have negative
numbers is that profits
can be negative and if you look at the
three
categories on on the left there
salesman can be non-profitable products
can be non-profitable customers can be
non-profitable
and when you add them all together you
get the 120 20 rules
but what's interesting was when we
i first heard this rule from my friend
don
bebo that's the bibo at the top there
he gave the talk and right about halfway
through the presentation
of one of my clients
got up and left and he came back about
five minutes later and then i
at the end of the presentations uh this
was a breakfast
uh meeting for ceos and he came
i talked to him and he said when i heard
that that just lit
got me all excited because what he what
he had he had five salesmen
so one of them was costing him a lot of
money he never wanted to sell what he
had he complained about things how fast
they got
serviced and on and on and on and then
he had another salesman
who's extremely profitable and would
give him
tell him what what he wanted and the guy
would go deliberate
and it was just really the difference
between a very profitable salesman and a
very costly salesman so what he did is
he went home
called up the guy and told him uh
i'm going to see you at 1 30 and fired
him
and he fired him because of uh he was
costing the company a lot of money and
the guy
understood that and then for the other
members of the team he put the
number one salesman in charge of the
team and the other three people
supported him so when he'd bring in
these orders
they would get handled efficiently by
the members of the team
and he could keep on the road bringing
in more and more
business
excuse me so at the end of that he
he always whenever i had a ceo breakfast
meeting he always wanted
to be invited because he said he gets
ideas from those
meetings uh
this is a thought that i like to throw
out to people what is work
work is really just
continually solving problems you come
into work
the order that you
had a part you had shipped to a client
didn't arrive
the customer's angry and calling people
in the company and you've got to solve
that problem
or customer calls it's a brand new piece
of software and
you know you got a bug and you gotta you
know you gotta research that and find
out what's going on with the software
and you know get back to the customer so
you're
a day is spent most for most people
trying to solve problems customer calls
up
to accounts uh
either accounts receivable or
uh if or accounts payable
and you have a problem that you end up
having to solve there it goes on and on
that's what your job is
solving problems and if it's a simple
problem i'll talk about that you just do
it
and then if it's a more difficult
problem you have to form a team
and uh
you know basically all problems you know
we're solved
are generated by people so the the
correlator to that is people gonna
gonna solve them and
but just a little note about the way i
look at problems is there are stupid
problems those are the ones that
you know we're talking about earlier
that part was late
you just do it you you spend your day
doing mostly stupid problems
at least i used to do that
you get a little more difficult problem
you need a team
it's either inside your work directive
that's where you work or outside your
directive you need to bring somebody in
from various departments
to help solve the problem and then you
get the wicked problem and that's
the one that involves
other people and then they can
potentially affect somebody in a
negative way
and you think of
trying to figure out how to balance
sales commissions and you're going to
end up changing
the sales commission plan because of
things changed in the companies
and you're going to end up with a lot of
angry people so that's a
that's a wicked problem at least from my
perspective
and and then you have
um the homeless problem and you know the
constituents that are affected
negatively by it you've got the
politicians
you've got the actual the homeless and
you've got all these
various groups that represent part of
the problem or
are part of the input to solve the
problem
unfortunately communities around the
us and i think around the world are
trying to solve the problem without the
homeless
and i i think that is the
problem with a wicked problem is that
you really got to get all the parts
that that could be affected by the
problems into the problem-solving
process
and i don't know if any of you know or
ever heard of occam's razor but when
you're trying to solve
problems you may end up with two or
three alternatives
always take the simplest of the
solutions
and and you probably won't be wrong
and and i sort of look at when you solve
problems people used to
ask if i was a problem solver and i said
well not really
because when uh
i solve a problem today it's going to be
a problem tomorrow so i'm more of a
problem creator
and and part of that is that you never
really want to do the 100
solution and if you do that you're going
to waste a lot of time and you're going
to get on that
curve that you saw with the 567 and
and the 80 20 rule at the right hand
side of that curve it goes
you know it goes to infinity on the cost
side
so you to get that hundred percent
solution
so live with less and get
uh progress uh towards solving the
problem
i'd like to talk a little bit about why
you really want a problem-solving
strategy and that is
the ceo could see trends in the problems
that are given to
to him or her if he can see
how the people are down in the trenches
and around the company are looking at
the issues that are coming up in an
inability to
deliver value and when the ceo can see
those trends then they can shift
the uh strategy to reflect that
so one of the things if you're ever any
of you or consultants and
or and or executives who are trying to
deal with strategy
is that it needs to be uh etched in sand
not in con not in granite you know you
don't chisel it in and
anchor it for 20 years it doesn't the
market won't allow you to do that
i'd like to talk about a a an issue
as it relates to some problems that
we've solved over the years and what it
did to the companies
and that's the answer the question of
does
problem solving align strategy with
process
or does it align process
with strategy and i'd like to take
take you through two examples one that
exhib
gives you as an example as a starter
manufacturing manufacturer they
remanufactured alternators generators
and starters and in that example
we were aligning strategy with process
and we'll go into that
the second example is one in which
the company had a strategy they wanted
to implement
but they didn't have the process to
deliver against that
and so they had to change the
manufacturing process so they ended up
aligning process with the strategy that
they wanted to implement
the remanufacturer starters and
alternators was a little company in
oakland california and
when i walked in there and we were
trying to
starting to look at a problem to solve
the issue was
how can we speed the process of
manufacturing
or remanufacturing the alternators and
starters
and generators that they were working on
in a day they were only generating
50 to 100 products out the door
and ultimately we ended up with 400 to
500 per day out the door
and the question is how did we do that
well what we we knew we wanted to
do something like a kanban which is you
you have
two bins filled with parts and you empty
one
and you send it to somebody to fill it
back up and he puts it back
in the back of the rack and you pull
from the front one and it's a very
simple process
and it turned out it worked perfectly
for this kind of a business
so we did an annual demand analysis of
the demand for the various
manufacturers of toyota for general
motors chrysler
and saw how many bins we would need
to accommodate all the different parts
that they had
and then we set up cells with those
four major art alternators on one side
of the
work area and starters on the other side
and we just set it up and
and had a teardown the teardown
processes
when the core came in that was the
material
um that
you know the raw material of the uh
that you pull out of the car that's the
core and you replace
the core with a new one you put it in
the car
hook it all up and the car takes off but
the core
then becomes the basis of it goes back
into a supply chain
that feeds back to this kind of
remanufacturer that i was working with
and so what we did was we figured out a
way
to uh create a rapid
turnaround of parts coming in there
by by simply following you know
uh process and i i work with the guys
most of them didn't speak english they
were spanish
and so we ended up
you know creating a pretty phenomenal uh
little uh
business but then one of the things that
happened
as a result of this we got pretty good
at remanufacturing the product line
but we also started to get some demand
for some old
car restorers that classic
let's say a 1953 chevy bel air that
would need a
starter or a 1957
or 47 pontiac or whatever there would be
a wide
range of these old cars that were being
restored
and the people that had those wanted
that turned around rapidly and it was a
new
opportunity because if you could turn it
around rapidly normally
uh you'd you could charge maybe 150 to
200 dollars for the unit
but if you could do it rapidly
you know have it available when the guy
walks in the door
um you know he calls up ahead of time
says i'd like to come by and pick it up
at
two o'clock three o'clock and you say
okay we'll have it for you
and you could charge four hundred
dollars the guy is in a hurry to get
going and he's willing to spend just
about anything
you've got a great market opportunity
so what we did is we set up a cell
to do the remanufacturing of the old
parts
and we set up a rack that had 400
different parts that we knew customers
would want
and each part had two shoe boxes
and in each shoe box we put one of the
cores
and if it was box was empty
you turn it around and there was a red
piece of tape on it
so once we got that
rack filled with parts then the job
became
one of negotiating a price of some of
those old parts
when you put an order in for all let's
say for
ten thousand dollars of course uh
four thousand of ford parks chrysler
so forth each of them about you know
totaling ten thousand dollars for an
order can they
you know get the guys to say can you
throw in a 1947 pontiac
uh core for
three or four bucks and the guy go okay
because that
that didn't make any difference it
didn't affect his profits
but then it became the profit source for
this guy so what happened is
on the rack you ended up with
800 parts and if
the parts were less than five dollars
you could end up with a total cost of
inventory
of four thousand dollars so now the ceo
or the owner of the business in this
case would go out and
walk the rack and he could just go down
go down the list
and check the feet the number of parts
that he needed
and if they were on a particular part if
there were two of them out he'd put a
circle around it and that would be on
his list
he would aggressively go after those
uh to fill it up because usually they
couldn't fill up one of the
you know they couldn't fill up the or
finish
assembling the unit with just one core
they needed maybe
two cores at a at a max to get it done
so what we ended up with
was the strategy changed from
optimizing the manufacturing time that's
what i did when i first came in there
that
that's what we did and we then moved the
strategy
over to now trying to optimize
the core price to increase
the uh margin that he would get when he
would sell the end product so that is
strategy
aligned with product in the second
example
there was a client of had
they made oligos
oligos are a chemical
segment of dna and researchers would
order the
holy ghost and they would be in a tray
of 300 part 300
chemical locations and they would
in in the actual
uh part they would order
let's say a bunch of oligo segments and
they wanted them in a particular order
on the
on the uh on on the tray
the that's what the clients wanted and
that's a market they wanted to get into
so the but they couldn't do it and
they didn't have the price to be
effective
compete in that because their old
technology their old process
wouldn't allow them to cost effectively
do that
they were charging what say like uh
let's say a buck or a
one one of the layers of dna
and then but they wanted to get it down
to about
uh 10 10 cents and so they ultimately
figured it out one of the guys came in
to me on the second day of class and
said
i have access to a
3 500 gantry robot
and the gantry robot will allow us to
get into the market of creating
low-cost holy ghosts for the research
market the large
orders i mean these were you know
five thousand to ten thousand dollar
orders
and it would it just positioned them as
a very
strong player in that market but i need
to do a pilot
and again this is where 567 came in and
he said i could get it done
because as soon as he heard me say 567
he got yeah that's what we're gonna do
so he got five percent of the features
that he needed
to get done and he said
in class oh i'd i'd like to come in and
take the members of my team and we're
going to go in the back room
and it's going to be a stealth project
for three or four weeks
and then when we make our pre
presentation which was usually
on the this was an eight-week class and
monday of the fourth monday of the fifth
week
we did presentations to the ceos
so on monday when
the ceo walked in to hear the other
here the presentations the first three
were well received and then the fourth
one
was this uh project and it blew the ceo
away and afterwards he asked me uh
why why didn't you tell me about that
you told me about all the others and he
goes
oh i was gonna be meddlesome and the
guys didn't want me there and i go
yep that was it so the
fun part of this is it was they became
the low-cost supplier
and became a leader in this particular
industry
with the an idea you know
completed by this individual and he led
the team and the team
worked with him to get it all done you
know there were mechanics in the
that he was working with and uh it
worked out
really well so
my thesis is this is that you know ceos
need a problem-solving strategy and i
basically laid out how we go about doing
that
and particularly today with gig workers
and remote personnel in 19 or 2019 we
had about 36 percent of the workers in
the u.s were gig workers
and i i didn't i haven't seen
any statistics on what it's projected to
be in the next
couple of years but i gave a ted talk
and the year 20
2025 was expected to be about 50
of the workers in the united states were
going to be
gig workers so
what the issue is is hiring people
and the question is do you hire somebody
that's a good worker or somebody that's
a good problem solver and and i say you
saw
get somebody who can solve problems and
you know by the way if somebody is good
at solving problems they're probably
going to be good at
work getting work done
let's talk about the uh
sixth pillar of my business and it's
our video teleconferencing platform
and this particular example we had a
client in paris one two in dallas
one in antwerp and one in kuala lumpur
and they were solving a problem and they
went through
the the six steps
of our problem solving process you know
identify the
waste find its root cause
size it solution
presentation management and finally
implementation
and measurement now what we learned just
as a
comment here that the ceos that i'm
working with now
on this system are paying more attention
to what i'm doing because i'm
being more precise
in the metrics that go into the sixth
step in other words we're not just
slapping some numbers up there to you
know to say
you know looks about right these are you
know precise numbers given to us by the
accounting department
people like that so our facilitator
uh manages and controls this process to
make sure that everybody
comes to class on time and that they
ultimately get the ceo to listen in or
whoever the
champion for the idea is and
so that becomes our sixth pillar and
it's the
you know the six pillars of the no blame
and powered team
the high roi of 101 uh
the 567 problem solving in our six step
process and then the video
teleconferencing
that's it thank you very much for taking
the time
sorry
yeah um i know you have some extra time
um and i wanted to see if
our audience was interested in some of
the
other projects you've done so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to
take back the sharing here
and i'm going to present a poll to the
audience
so this is this is a choose two because
we don't have time to do online
but um let me put up the polling widget
for our webex
viewers
and you have 45 seconds you can vote for
two
please don't vote for more than two
um so if you can give a brief rundown on
what these are
yeah um very quickly um
i did a project with a food processing
company they did vegetable
distribution and they had a plant
in uh pasadena they actually had five
plants and they consolidated them into
one
but during the training uh problem
solving one of the guys
thought that jesus we could put a truck
out in the field and have it do
all the collection of the vegetables in
the field
uh have it set up to do the washing and
ultimately uh
boxing of the vegetables that they go
directly from the field
to the store and uh
maybe pass to the distribution center
and then
very quickly move out to the store and
so that was a
very interesting idea and that same
company there's one of the guys had an
idea for doing a sous chef
and a truck you know they'd have a truck
moving around los angeles and they would
effectively
serve the hotels down in los angeles
would have
and they basically got the order from
the
uh restaurant of what how much uh
what particular uh salads they want
prepared
for your head and they were delivered uh
within an hour so it it became a neat
little business
that that i thought was pretty cool um
we've got the result of the poll um and
the two um projects that people
would like you to go into detail on
um are the angry employee who solved the
hot jobs problem
and um the rest of the story about the
ceo who reduced
the sales force and increased the sales
yeah uh let me take the angry employee
first
that's one of my favorite stories um we
were
working at this uh spring manufacturer
and
they uh one of the employees
or actually a team of five people were
on a team and they
were uh not making any progress on the
team
and just as a as a sidebar is that if
when you when you uh
try to solve problems when you're
struggling to find one
usually if you come to work and
something pisses you off
it's usually a big problem and so
i walk up to this team and uh after com
being out in the shop floor with a bunch
of the other
members of the team uh
of the company and um i
saw them sitting there and i asked them
and they can piss you off and one of the
guys oh
god you know hot jobs pissed me off
and i said well what's a hot job and he
said well
the guy's up in front office you know
they
get a call from a customer and they
absolutely need something tomorrow
and i tear down my machine to respond to
that
and in this particular case the teardown
was like six seven hours
and you know he would maybe not be able
to complete it on his shift and then the
guy in the second shift would have to
finish it up
and start the production and so he said
what really makes me mad that's not
you know i can live with that but what
happens is
you go you go out on the shop floor
right now there are red tags
all over of jobs that were hot
last week or three days ago or five days
ago
then he said if they were hot why aren't
they gone and
so right about that time the reason this
is funny is that
right about that time the ceo came in
and he'd been out talking to the other
teams and he was all jazzed
because this is fun this is exciting to
solve problems
and get the ceo all excited
you know all the employees you know it
it really
changes the culture of the company
because you know you get the ceo
involved man this is great
so he walks in and he comes over and
saying hey what are you guys working on
and
he and i said uh i
said they're working on hot jobs and he
goes
and he says to the team he said no no we
solved that problem about three or four
months ago when the guy's
just living and he stands up he
slams his hand down on the table and he
says we
didn't solve it you solved it up front
but not
down in my area and you know the owner
of the business he goes
whoa and i said okay
and about that time i've been listening
and i sort of knew what the problem was
the problem was long setups so
i said told the ceo i said i think we
can work on this we got some ideas
to move it forward he goes okay keep me
informed
so he took off and then i went
went out oh excuse me let me
step back
because the ceo said that they had
solved it and the guy was angry i said
okay one
you know the ceo you take these three
people
and you know the other guy took two
people
and i said i want you to take a pad of
yellow ruled paper and go out
and find uh
red tag jobs that are still there
and they came back in about and you've
only got 15 minutes to do that
so they came back in in 15 minutes and
the ceo had his
pad filled up and the other guy had his
pad filled up
and the ceo goes oh
so then once he did that he goes i'll
step back and let you go forward lin
so we so what the issue was
was set up setup was taking six to seven
hours but there's a
one of the things you can do in the
toyota production system is think
through
what they call smed and you know you you
think about all the things that you can
do while the job is running
the next job is coming along and those
are external setups
and you separate those from the internal
setups the things you can only do
when the machine is shut down and so by
reorganizing that and
speeding up the turnaround of the jobs
we were able to get it down to less than
an hour
and the
end result of that was
hot jobs if it became hot
the guy the people in production would
finish the job they were on
then the next the hot job would move to
the front of the queue and be the next
one to run
now when they ran production
it was they were able to uh
stay ahead of the hot jobs and
everybody's anger went down and
everything was was cool but
the issue in that particular case was
that it was something i knew
how to go about fixing because i've seen
similar issues in different companies
and so one of the things about that that
was really fun
was it turned all those
members of that team into you know they
were all excited because they
when they gave their presentation
uh the the guy that stood up and slammed
his hand down he sort of led the
presentation
and he he uh
this the father of the
ceo who was sitting in the room started
to interrupt him
and this guy was confident enough that
he had
knew what he was talking about he says
just
hold it there wait till i'm done he said
that to the
father of the ceo and
so it was really interesting because
this is a guy that didn't didn't talk
that's what he told me
i'm a part of american indian
we don't talk a lot and he was he was
jabbering away it was and so it was
really a fun
overall story um
i i hope that you you get the message of
that one is that you know sometimes when
you're trying to solve
a problem people open the front office
tried to change the
tried to fix the problem by
by themselves without getting the people
in the shop floor involved that if
they'd had done that
they'd have realized what the real
problem was that the root cause
was set up time
okay the other problem with the uh
the sales uh fired the salesman yeah
yeah yeah well when that happened
i i went with this ceo when i was with
him in the meeting and
this company made remit
remanufactured airplane parts and
they uh they would get orders from
you know
you know uh airplane companies around
the world
would ship car loads of
truckloads of of parts in to get fixed
and then they would the employees there
would you know
they'd break up the borders into
different parts like gyroscopes and
all the other parts that were part of
the electronic
uh parts of the repair
program and so they
their market was international and
so when they would be when they would
complete the parts they would be
shipping out
almost a container load of of
completed parts and they were you know
they were
approved by the faa to you know to do
these kind of repairs
and so when the guy who was selling
would go out and get an order
it was a pretty complicated thing to get
the five
you know get the orders in and and the
one thing he hated to do was
spend that time uh
filling out the forms and getting
everything right because that's not the
way he was
built you know he wasn't a detailed guy
he'd get the order
bring it in the door and wanted other
people to fill it out and that was what
he got
he got these other guys that were more
meticulous were able to get the orders
in
and the net result is they all made more
money
uh i had a similar
you know just as a parallel uh
experience in a
uh you know 20
25 years ago there was a computer store
called microage and there were
a num i did a number of uh
microage stores and one of them served
the aerospace industry and
it was the same kind of a thing you had
one guy that was really a good salesman
and then there were a lot of
uh so they set it up
so that he would have two people working
for him
to uh to handle the detail of the orders
he would go get
and over the years i've i've
that that sort of scenario
fell naturally in place at a number of
other companies so
the message of that was that
uh the 120 rule of 120
20 rule of profits applied there as well
and uh uh just as a
a little speaking of 120 20
profits the a lot of times when you're
trying to
think of how to solve let's say if
you've got a
one of the clients i had did roof
trusses
or homes new homes
and clients would call in and
say they had a bunch of job
houses to quote uh the trusses for
and then they would never give the guy
business
and uh and he
wanted to know um
what we could do and uh so we we
actually
measured because this is the difficulty
sometimes
how do you measure the waste associated
with
something like that where the guy was
giving you a lot of wasting a lot of
your time so what we did is we actually
got
they listed all the clients that they
had and the number of orders that they
had
put in for the year and how many dollars
they made
so there was a direct correlation
between
how many orders of uh
a good customer put in and how many
dollars they got from it
and then the other guys that put in you
know maybe the same number of requests
and gave them no business
and the reason that was a problem is it
was taking up capacity of his
engineering group to prepare the quotes
back to the
home builder that was doing the work and
so that
that's another issue by the way thank
you stuart for putting that up
um any other questions
yes as it happens we've got quite a few
questions so what i'm going to do is uh
if you give me a moment here i will
get those up and i'll be able to share
some of those with you
so um
we had a an interesting question
about the culture
see if i've got that question up here
pardon me for leaning into the camera
i'm going to ask a question from uh
how do you motivate people to
acknowledge and own problems
sometimes problem owners hesitate to
acknowledge and know the problem
if they're aware of it and they avoid it
uh i don't if if you've got a problem
and you don't own it then
i i'm i'm not able to help you but
what i try to do is
like right now i get five people from a
company online
and they have a problem that they've
identified
and then they work it
work it through but if you have somebody
and over the years have been you know
people that
you know get angry when you try to
implement something and i call those
people
black knights because they don't want to
change
and the term black knight came up
uh there's a you can do uh
google search on uh
monty python running python
black knight and there's a scene in
which the black knight
is defending a bridge and he and the
king arthur
just comes up to the bridge and this
night black knight is fighting this
other bridge other night
and he kills him and
then king arthur comes up and he says
good sir knight why don't you come join
me in camelot
uh and he said it says nothing he said
oh we'll stand aside and let me cross
the bridge and the black knight
won't and he proceeds they proceed to
get into a fight
the black knight loses both his arms and
legs and he's
a stump on the ground and he refuses to
give in and uh
you know if you if you look back at that
from a lot of from my perspective it's
it's humorous because
king arthur could have said okay i don't
want to cross your bridge i'll just jump
over the creek
and the creek was like a you know
12 inches wide and he could have easily
jumped around jumped over it but
the point was is that the black knight
denied that he had a problem
so in answer to your question
if somebody refuses to acknowledge that
he's got a problem
then you have a difficult time
uh working with that person
but if you've got a directive and so
what i've always done
is i've worked with the ceo and the ceo
said
fix my business or make it better and
the end result of that is that you end
up
with um encountering a lot of
uh two or three black knights and uh
even in a hundred
hundred man company you end up with
uh two or three black knights that
you know do not want to participate in
the program
do not want to change anything and
you know when they see that the ceo is
got my back
they they most of them back down
but uh
on occasion you know ceos had to say you
know
look at you either get on board or you
know i think you
may find some other place to work and
that you know over 200 clients i've
worked with that's been
what two people have refused to get on
and um
yeah i was just going to say we had a a
couple of questions about people
uh asking about the six steps of
uh problem solving can you go over that
because i think uh on the slide where it
appears it's kind of a
small print so if you could go over
those six steps
that would help yeah the six steps are
one identify the problem
step one step two
is look for the root cause
that like i noted earlier is that it's
not always crystal clear but it's the
we spend time going over that and the
third step
is actually sizing the waste
you identify the problem and you try to
figure out
how much is that costing the company
in the course of a year so for instance
in the case of the
hot jobs project i was talking about
if you look at the number
of jobs that ran through the business
and the amount of time it was taking to
do setup
the company was able to recover about 15
percent
i i you know the number is 30
years ago or 20 years ago
it was about 15 percent
of the revenue of the business
and it was a you know it was a
25 million a year business and
you know so that's a substantial amount
of money to
look at from an annual basis and
you know so there's a
you know every time you look at a
problem you're trying to figure out how
how am i going to figure out how big
this is and
you know the question the most difficult
question i've ever had to deal with is
when you call into a company and you're
put on hold
for more than you know five ten minutes
what does that cost the company and how
do you measure that
and you know over the years we figured
out you know
ways that uh more importantly to
eliminate that than to necessarily
figure out how
big the problem was you knew it pissed
people off
but it was not an easy thing to to size
that's the
third step the fourth step is
coming up with the solution and then
the solution has to be com
you know has to come comply with the
100 to 1 roi
and that's you know that's the goal
i mean you you don't have an option
there because if
for instance you find you know two
million dollars worth of
waste a hundred to one on that is twenty
thousand dollars
and and when you try to solve a problem
for twenty thousand dollars to get rid
of two million dollars of waste
it uh
you know it may be it it's hard
so i'm not saying this is this is easy
but it forces people to think of
the problem in terms of uh
getting a high return on the on the
problem so for instance if you
are working on a project and you only
get 20 to one
do you think that the management of the
company is going to be mad at you
no they're not that's a good deal
because what is 20 to one it says you're
going to pay off the project in two and
a half weeks
pretty good deal so
my reason for from the beginning for
doing it is because i tried a couple of
numbers and they kept getting bigger and
bigger
and so initially i was doing
uh 20 to one and then i realized man we
can get 50 to one
pretty easily and it moved it up to 50
to wood
and then when i got to the bigger
companies i cranked it up to 101
and then the solution is
the uh
you know when when you're that's the
fourth step and the
fifth step is your presentation to the
ceo
and that presentation consists of
making sure that you've covered
what it is you're going to do what kind
of implementation plan you've got
all the details of how you're going to
get rid of that problem or make it
a substantial part of it go away and
then
the last step is the actual
implementation and metrics
that measure the success of the project
over the year
and that that's uh and that's it and
but you know it's not this you know one
of the things that
people say you know they say hey lynn
i've got a friend of mine who's the
operations manager and he
would like to do something and uh if
it's a small company i would say
let's get to meet the ceo because
uh problem solving ultimately as i
indicated in the presentation is a is a
strategic issue
and the ceo alone is responsible for
strategy
uh other executives can be in charge of
uh tactics but the ceo's responsibility
is figuring out the strategy for the
company and then managing it
anything else the sixth step is oh you
just went over the implementation
and um so yeah we have a
question about putting this in the
context of digital transformation
um and also you've done
projects that have been in the
quote-unquote digital domain where
the process that you've you've analyzed
has been something like a web-based
process or a computerized process within
the client
right so can you can you mention about
uh
something about that context well the
first one was the example i gave of uh
of the of the gantry robot
to handle the holy ghost that was a
a big time digital transformation
because it was you're
you're using a gantry robot which is
automation
to improve on a process that had been in
play for about 10
12 years and so that was my
one of my good examples
another one was uh
in the the gantry in
in the company that made uh roof trusses
it was a gradual progression
of digital transformation of that
company from
where it was to where it was going and
in order to get the company fixtured
into thinking in terms of the systems
associated with
automation and digital transformation
you
you need to complete the step of getting
the systems repl you know working
so that now you know what's going to
work
and what's not and in that particular
case we
started at the drawing of a
of a home and from that
sent the signal to the saws
to cut the parts that were needed
to go into the roof truss then the
parts would go from there over
and they'd be marked with uh
digital uh stamping to tell you what
part it was
they would go over to a table where the
people were assembling that unit
would be able to uh efficiently
put the trust together and then the
next step was automating that whole
thing and that happened
in the next three or four years another
uh another example of just
sort of the progression from the
from the improved 100 to 1 or 50 to 1
to an automation process was
a company that made
and irons and fireplace equipment
they did a lot of welding and so once we
cleaned up the welding process so that
things moved smoothly
into and out of the welding process then
it was just a matter of
an easy process to put a
robotic welder to replace the
uh individuals that were doing the work
because that that was a it was just
back-breaking work and it was
you know the guys they had doing it were
like six four six five
and big big fellows
and so one of the things that you didn't
do
is is when you do the automation process
is you have to look
you know once you've cleaned up sort of
the back end of something
uh back office then you you start to
look
at um cleaning up
the you know then you have room for
automation
but in a machine
i don't i don't know whether i'm
answering the question or not but
uh one more example would be the machine
shop that i work with
uh the very very very first machine shop
that
we got set up time down to less than you
know 15
20 minutes and then it was
very easy to move from
that point to a mach
machines nc machines
that would take the programs from
the source the
company that would make the want you to
make the part
they would ship the instructions for
that
or the drawing for that part over to
this company's
uh engineering department
they would have the commands set up to
do the cutting of the part
and that was all automated and
they could the client was a very large
semiconductor equipment company and they
would get the order
from that that semiconductor company
they'd get the order and have a part
back to them within an hour two hours
and so what that did was it went from
you know instead of doing
batches of 50 to 100 or
they were able to do small orders kanban
to deliver the parts to the company
and then they moved up gradually into
the automation
step by step and uh
you know taking images from you know
computers and turning them over to a
machine
doing that very efficiently and quickly
but it was they cleaned
they cleaned the business up first and
then they
got all the digital transformation done
right and that that's the that's the
whole point here
is that um if you start
from the digital digital transformation
or the robotic process automation side
and say let's take our processes and
make them automated
then what you've done is you
you're basically applying technology
to accomplish the same thing with the
same amount of
waste so for the other example you gave
which was you know
how much does it cost if you're on hold
for five minutes
in a call center well you can automate
the call center
but if it's still putting people on hold
for five or ten minutes
um maybe there's a little bit less labor
involved but the
problems of call abandonment and
customer dissatisfaction and all the
other ways
are still there so before you go into
that automation you want to go
to the business problem find
the sources of waste apply the six steps
and and
and then after you're cleaning up the
business
yeah it's it's it's uh
is that when you when you try to
understand
any business you go in and you watch
what's going on
you see it one person running around
a lot you understand why is that person
running around
you know and
you know you see things but you get a
better understanding of what the
business is all about
and then you know then it's it's what
they call
what i call lickety-split but you do not
want to automate
waste that's what you don't want to do
right
now you and i were involved in that
early on
yeah yeah um uh we have some questions
um regarding how you'd advise somebody
to become a better problem solver what
the what the skill set is for
for the problem solver and especially
one of our youtube audience
asks what you'd advise young persons to
do in terms of the kinds of projects
they'd
look to become part of to solve and
exercise those skills
um first of all you
if you want to become a better problem
solver
you end up you have to almost follow the
rules that i laid out you have to be
open to listening to other people
you know if you go in to the problem
solving process
thinking you're the smartest person in
the room it ain't going to work
and so what i i try to encourage people
to
to keep an open mind um
because that you know you know everybody
has an input and i
over the years i've just been blown away
by the insight that some low-level
manager had a low-level person had
that was very insightful and so you want
to
accept that that idea then you also
have to really work from the no blame
and understand what that means is that
you
cannot be in a position to either blame
or lay guilt on someone
for having managed something especially
if you're a manager and you're trying to
get people to solve problems for you
but the the most important thing is
understanding that let's say if you go
back to your job and you say
geez i listened to lynn and he was all
excited about
problem solving and
and
he gave us some ideas about what
problems that we could attack and so
if you want to attack a problem
find a champion don't try to do it
yourself i mean if you
uh i mean businesses
are uh rife with people that want to
you know cut your legs out from under
you if you're not
tactical
tactical about what you're doing so you
want to find somebody that's going to
support
your effort that's a champion and then
once you've gotten that person on board
and um you know
then then you can proceed to follow the
process i laid out you know the six
steps
and you know if you if you
get hung up in an issue i said just
email me
and um you know
give my 10 cents and help you
just for having um
listened to me for an hour
last last question i'm going to ask
because
we're reaching 90 minutes um
alejandra asks some organizations have a
conflict of interest on
certain issues and and
you know individuals may not be focused
on the the greater good for the company
um so how do you
how do you deal with that if you're in
the company you're trying to solve
problems
and you find either people next to you
above you below you
are engaged in that kind of self-serving
behavior
you know i every every group every comp
company has its own culture
and people behave to new ideas and lots
of different ways for lots of different
reasons
and and when you
when you
when you're trying to to deal with
people that are are unwilling to work
with you
or unwilling to support you there's
bound to be other people that will work
with you
and uh
that's why i'm saying if you if you have
an idea that you want to work on find a
champion
and that's i mean i
from my experiences now after having
been doing this for 35 years i wouldn't
try anything without getting a champion
behind me that was really
wanting to support what i was trying to
do
and that and that and the ideal champion
is you know the
ceo of the company or that type of thing
right right the ideal is the ceo
and um
you know a lot of times you know you
know if you want to
uh embolden your presence with the ceo
you can always
always do this and ceos are always
excited about people that want to go
take on a challenge um
but the but the key to trying to any of
these things
is the 567 is that
you know when you make your case look at
i i listen to lynn talk
and he's he's big into the 567 you can
buy my book and read about it or you can
go to the internet and
find a youtube pitch that i give
and you know you could find more about
the 567
and understand what it is
but it's it's you know when you go to a
ceo and talk to him about that
and he he goes wrong that's interesting
and then
uh you know and then
it'll noodle for a couple of days and
maybe he'll get back to you and say go
forward
um but i as far as advice
you know i uh
i don't know ever know what the best
advice to anyone is when it comes to
getting started once you get started you
know i go to
under the ceo and i work down from there
but a lot of times you know you're a big
enough company where you can't get to
the ceo
but you could find somebody else that's
high level to support the idea
and and if you if for instance if you
just took what i did with the
567 but but the six
steps and you outlined your idea
in a memo to somebody um
you know to tell them what you'd been
you know if you do the preliminary work
on it
and write it up i said i need more time
to collect with the team to collect them
more accurate data for you but this is a
this is a sketch of what the problem
might look like and
the guy goes wow you'd be surprised when
you just
do that when you if you think about the
problem you're thinking of
and in those terms and just sort of size
it
how much it's costing the company in a
year
you know i work at a semiconductor
company and i'd go to meetings
and i kept track of
every single meeting i went to for six
months
and i get there at 10 o'clock and people
would
meander in 15 minutes later and then the
meeting would start
and i kept track of all those and if i
got there at
10 and then people meandered in it five
minutes late
then that was only a waste of five
minutes
per person that wandered in at that time
and if somebody wandered in eight
minutes and so forth i kept track of all
that
and then at the end of six months i
totaled it and sent it to the ceo and
he went absolutely
seat and so from that point forward is
you know the rule was is you get the
meetings on time you don't schedule
meetings back to back to back to back
you and even to this day if you go down
to this company
you can see a signal sign in every room
basically caused by my data
but um you know when people
are wasting people's time and what's
that translate into
you know that's a big deal and
you know i mean just but also you can be
a pariah if you do that
you know you you do something like that
people are gonna
you know which they did a little bit but
they knew i was
petulant so that was okay
all right um len has offered that we'll
take uh the questions that we've been
collecting from the audience
and i'll i'll send those to him and
he'll be able to
send us a follow-up about a week from
now
um but in the meantime it's all the time
we have
the live questions so i'm going to go
ahead
and run one last
quick poll about um
people's interests in learning
and
we have been putting into the
chat window some links to simply learn
programs
but let's um let's run this quick pull
and
different skills that you can look into
that will help you in the world digital
transformation and
digital economy and some idea of
when you would like to get started
and learning about them
sorry i
used my mouse wheel the wrong time
and we'll close the poll in five seconds
and not surprisingly for this audience
um business and project management
um are is the most interesting
subject for people um and about 40
of you said you'd like to get started
right away
which is always a good idea so with that
i'm going to
say thank you to lynn here's his
linkedin information it's just basically
lindbertain linkedin.com
um you can also
go ahead you cannot you can also
just get me by emailing me lynn ellion
at bertain.com
that's pretty straightforward and uh
i want to thank lynn for being here
today and being very generous with this
time
we've got a lot of comments from people
about how much they've appreciated this
this session so thank you len
i want to mention again the skill up
program that we have
which is access to
our training content for free it
includes our video content for
self-study so it gives you a flavor for
the actual courses we provide we do
give you a completion certificate if you
complete a self-study program through
skill up and again it's a free program
covers hundreds of skills and thousands
of hours of video content
i've dropped the link into the chat a
few times so you can
check that and you can keep track
of us at our social media handles simply
learn at simply learn on facebook and
twitter and
we're simply learning on linkedin as
well um
we have another webinar coming up
and we'll try to include information
about that in the follow-up email
from this webinar which will include a
link to the recording here
i know a number of you have asked about
getting the slide deck from
lan it's proprietary information so we
can't share that
but yeah we will share the link to this
recording so that you can review the
information
at your leisure and um with that
uh the webinar is concluded so thank
i thank you all to be for being here and
sticking through to the end and we hope
to see you at future simply learn
webinars
you